denzel washington had quite the surprise
on last night's jimmy kimmel live as he
was surprised by a 91 year old
grandmother named juanita who he
actually first met back in 2017 in a
viral video where he was seen meeting
juanita's hopefully in chicago
uh yeah so leave jimmy kimmel to track
down juanita and put together a sweet
reunion video chat take a look at this
again you're in chicago
and um you were looking for like a
barbecue place right yeah i was looking
from where my cousins used to live okay
yeah and uh well take a look
[Music]
what's up little man you don't know who
i am but they'll tell you one day what's
your name
my name is denzel
that's it
she has got a hold of you
so she would not let me go either we
track juanita down and the fact she's
with us right now
[Applause]
you should remember me i'm wearing the
same shirt so you would remember me me
too
okay
juanita hi it's jimmy i just wanted to
say uh well first i wanted to ask you
you were 87 years old in that clip how
old do you mind me asking are you now
i am 91. 91.
you look incredible incredible and 91
one even like 19.
were your friends jealous when they
found out you had a visit from denzel i
know everyone was happy everyone was so
happy to see him
and they are still calling me asking me
whenever i heard from him i never heard
them insisting
i'm thankful that i got in touch with
him today
you didn't give me your number
you sent your son back to give me a kiss
i thought i didn't have time to give it
to me because you was in a hurry
and denzel teach faith and keep making
movies all right i'll be safe too
i'll keep making shows thank you juanita
hubbard everybody